[موسيقى]
لم يبدا بذلك لان الناس كانوا مكملين قبل
الثوره
فلما ازيل المانع اراد الجميع ان يتكلم
ويتكلم في وقت واحد لم نسمع بعضنا نحن
تشوفنا
وشوقنا واعطشنا الى ان يعبر عن انفسنا
جعلنا لا نحترم بعضنا والذين يتكلمون في
وقت واحد لا يبلغون ولا يدركون نحن نحتاج
اليوم الى شكل من اشكال الهدوء
ليتحدث الجميع وليفيد الجميع وليسمع
الجميع
التنوع هو الذي يمكن ان يقودن الى التغيير
وينبغي ان نعود اذاننا على ان نستمع ما
نحبه وما نكرهه والا نقول الا ما يحب
غيرنا ولو كرهناه نحن
[موسيقى]
منذ ان حدثت هذه الاحداث وانا عايشتها
وعصرتها
وتابعها
لان ليس لي قدره على ان اخرج من هذا الصمت
فردا انا استمع الى مواطني كيف يعلقون
ارغب في ان تنتهي هذه المرحله تنتهي بفاق
الوطني ما حصل قد حصلت سواء كان ايجابيا
او سلبيا
ليس من دوري ان اشجبه او اشكر عليه ولكن
انتظروا ان نصل نحن الى خاتمتي هذا المسار
بشكل من اشكال التوافق الوطني
[موسيقى]